I'll do the rest my name is pierre de ba
welcome back to bully we're gonna go on
a date a hot date with a cheat a lie
every boy's dream right there alright so
we have to go in town to get her stuff
to make her I didn't say anything
all right we need you best actually [ __ ]
I don't have Vespa or bike awesome just
for the biking bro I can jump with my
bag I can jump with my bag I can job
with my bag I can jump with my back oh
sorry is it do you want your backpack
you want your bike bag mmm Kent has Go
Go woman so first stop I'll be over here
[ __ ] Lolo jumps off the violence I
don't give a [ __ ] into the corner storm
oh [ __ ] for the collection I just have
to take it I don't have to pay or
anything
oh [ __ ] they're after me oh [ __ ] what do
I do pretend to be a garbage bin no I
didn't fall for that back off [ __ ] I
got a geek hot teacher to F I go I begun
and the next one is Here I am
don't even care I need to get a new
sweater to get my oh how are you today I
can use that Oh pearl necklace am I
really the best dressed in Bulworth I
must be job you can fly to me ha I made
really no you're not
ah you guys just don't quit don't you
where's Mike Mike save me bet just bet
just with snitch in my snitches
jumping alright the last one it's in the
other side of time and our last stop is
help it's here
what is this some great ooh I wonder if
I can wear this all alive I might need
that
you want that for your next party she's
standing inside the booth yes
cool just curious I was wanting a
lasagna these guys never [ __ ] quit
Jesus well good thing out his bike had
plenty of time
maril [ __ ] are you doin we're gonna get
laid
we gonna get laid we're gonna gonna
gonna gonna gonna get laid son all right
that I don't know where I was going with
that song I'm gonna get laid we're the
hot teacher I don't even know how to get
off my by the end best song oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] it let's run it's not like
they're gonna it's not like they're
gonna you know stop me
all right teacher it's time mmm here you
go how do I let shimmy what took you so
long
Thanks how's angle Southwick oh man I
can't believe this my first time with a
teacher your first time ever hey Julie
what are you doing here nothing what are
you doing here ah uh uh well it's a
little awkward but since you've been
such a good friend to me miss Phillips
she's asked me me of all people the [ __ ]
are you doing can you believe she's
asked me on a date wit she asked you I
think your mistake she's written white
yeah I mean I think there's been some
sort of mistake you sure you haven't
been hitting the bottle again you've
been talking about I mean yes I am of
course look even hitting the bottle you
had bottles all I know you came you look
great so do you dear drunkard I'm
getting you wait what Jimmy what are you
still doing here uh what do you mean
yeah
this boy is an angel he's been
magnificent uh engineman are so cute
you're not a sucks come on Lionel let's
go
hi Jimmy Jimmy you should get back to
school what's q8 miss Phillips it's in
the middle of the night why'd you lie go
back to school ah man I thought I was
now I'm a fighting stance
no dance for that one where who paid me
for that Lily who paid me is talking
about my butt come on get up
[ __ ] I'm pets now well now I'm pissed
this is going on a rampage now I'm gonna
egg your mama
hey-ya hey-ya [ __ ] the police [ __ ] the
police [ __ ] [ __ ] the police [ __ ] um oh
they can't catch me
you can never catch me let it go let it
die [ __ ] the police [ __ ] - Poli
no no no no well it's not changing
anything all right I'll do say they're
so damn shame I tell you a damn shame
it's left it was nice I thought about
the teacher stop [ __ ] and miking me
to these goddamn grubs [ __ ] well what's
wrong with this place
all right we'll start a new one which
one Libre son huh
actually some of you were complaining
that I was being too much direct the
Explorer so I'm gonna [ __ ] it choose
this time how about that say I was just
trying to be nice and then a year
brothers decide which one which one you
can use or whatever shut up
but no alright a football is my guy
friend oh no
but buddy you came back to me I love you
alright let's check out the question
side shut up I'm not coming with anyone
alright there's another quest here with
the same teacher hello friend yeah yeah
yeah Galloway away what the hell is
Emmie
oh she's right miss Phillips hey Jimmy
what is she drawing that really happened
to mr. Galloway yeah where you go
it's a sad story but sometimes when
grown-ups get upset they respond in the
wrong ways and well mm small problems
get bigger now is she talking about
really the thing about being an adult
miss I'm not five my mom's been married
five times and I've been expelled from
seven schools mm-hmm
yeah he's a drunk stupid man couldn't
control himself damn him I love him as a
side but that wretched ogre hatrick
guilt-tripped him into committing
himself into the asylum to get dried out
at least someone could get in there and
tell him to get out I'll take care of
him wait he went to this island laws
that loveless scumbag hat-trick told him
not to let me in said I was a bad
influence
don't you worry miss I'll get him out
okay meet me near the asylum tonight
I'll be there and Jimmy yeah yes miss
Phillips its MS not miss oh right
so what so why she took him my away my
rights
that's [ __ ] faster to walk this has
not been open before
or has it why the [ __ ] am i what is this
great what girl what is this place
me oh okay that's what I'm doing that's
like a weird shortcut there what in the
hell what on the hams what in the earth
where's your mom I don't even know why
would they have an acylium here what is
going on
Jase whoa she drives knife glad you made
it
I'm glad you're here hurry and try to
talk some sense into him
I'll be waiting for him at the asylum I
mean what what other teacher we'll let
you know you so their students go to a
celebs for them make sense if you ask me
uh hello Fran I and re visiting time is
over
but so you have to beat me up hey I just
came here I just came I just came here
and this is crazy but here's my number
so [ __ ] running mmm
mm-hmm all right kids got this kids got
the moves where you going
ah all right there seems to be a secret
entrance
surveillance cameras doesn't matter I'll
just use this tree duck done damn bam
bam boom boom boom boom boom Wow who
goes to a NASA limb if they have a
drinking problem you're supposed to jump
down not drop your stop rubbing your
bottom there Grinch wrench [ __ ]
whatever stop rubbing your button you're
not a monkey man you're not a monkey
there we go but the thought is that what
are you doing what are you doing
what is that Hannibal Lecter destroy the
statues power saw the statue halves a
power source I think I'm the one who
needs some insane asylum alright I guess
I'm following this guy that looks like
he crapped his pants the [ __ ]
um eight smells too
I don't know why I'm so close a garden
gnome listen troublemaker just scram all
right what did I fail ah [ __ ] me
you aren't allowed to be here house
behind the bread bush ah
stell of quests not my type of quest
all right we're going we're going
I got him no don't get distracted from
the garden gnome pits do not do not I
repeat it's a garden gnome it's gorgeous
I want it why does the statue have a
power destroy it
cast the ring in the fire Frodo there we
go
I did it I took a picture of the garden
gnome and my life is not going to play
garden gnome you're coming with no what
am i doing what am i doing handmade that
[ __ ] I nailed that [ __ ]
I'm now lebed sneaks through taslim and
find miss Galloway okay okay this is a
little scary but it's okay sneaking self
it's self pears shed don't go now oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm going I'm going
I love you doing here I was smelling
your nipples [ __ ] oh ah
I was that close that close
I just amber I just shut the [ __ ] up
now that nail that nail it nail it nail
that nail
hello drunk it oh yeah dad cost me a lot
of try must be a better person I must be
a better person I must be a better
parent amore God I am pathetic
I'll a mr. Galloway go away I don't want
to have another group therapy session
with those people if I have to pretend
to be someone's mother one more time oh
I kiss her now what earthy you're doing
here miss Phillips sent me she's really
worried about you yet come on let's get
out of here I can't get laid at least
you get laid
ah I can't right now Jimmy I'm late for
my regression therapy as it is it's
fantastic I've discovered I really do
hate myself that's Patrick was right I
am a loser no you're not
don't be ridiculous come on we can't let
bullies like mr. hat-trick win who's
mrs. Jimmy Patrick see wearing a hat ha
ha ha daddy
ha ha ha everyone leaves in asylum like
that ha ha ha it's a gun golly bareback
oh you got there I'll do a little sexy
dance for that one I don't know who I
that's how I danced sexily by the way my
work here is done
my whack oh you oh you oh I'm not done
with you bit my die hell didn't go I
missed that rubberband I don't know how
to get home they could have given me a
ride those [ __ ]
alright next quest which one should i do
I don't even carry this is Dora the
bully the Explorer which quest should I
do next browse that one with the star ha
ha ha all right
that's steroid bras that's
I can't name bamm-bamm
nice outfit I like the son of that quest
hey Jimmy I've had a brilliant idea
many are called but few are chosen
okay luckily for you I've chosen you to
help me carry out this little
masterpiece I'm so not interested work
what are you talking about you lunatic
yeah talking about what we're always
talking about amigo
tell me about bullying the bully's
genius my favorite dish
saman Oh revenge against who who do you
think the football team goes over
developed under brained Lords of our
little Manor reduced to a bunch of
sniveling wretches bowing down to my you
mean our yeah I meant our superiority us
ruling like gentlemen over the peasants
us us yes you ruling of course me
offering some sage advice doing all the
thinking that sort of thing Merlin to
your king Arthur whatever what's the
plan well first we need you to get the
school mascot cost how do you suggest I
do that well hmm go follow them wait for
us to distract the gorillas go while we
still have hope Jason his banners
reminds me of a certain party around the
1940 45-ish years
that it wasn't very nice all right so we
got to go beat up the mascot hello
friends hi it hurts so good what the
[ __ ] pins run for their [ __ ] going for
the touchdown
where's it go to attach up it throws it
out a [ __ ] get in scores sorry about
that
you should call ladies [ __ ] oh there
is what you think you're going
what are you thinking family right I'll
shed the gym teachers here I didn't I
wasn't me a gym teacher balls inspection
what the [ __ ] you think you're going
beating up all the bullies one by
[ __ ] one
ma'am no I was just gonna care laughs
these guys
oh no no no I'm running out of hell did
I do it and I do it you saw it oh ha ha
ha
Oh we'll see what
that ain't what what the [ __ ] is going
on Oh interesting
all right
Oh we'll see about that come at me bro
bro bro come at me bro
Bam Bam Bam Bam was that B Stanford eh
ha ha ha ha ha Bambi ha ha oh [ __ ] I ran
out of helis I didn't look at my house
ah we're back with a bowl and this I got
full health on this [ __ ] come at me bro
I'll just slingshot that bed oh it's
actually really ineffective [ __ ] I don't
even know what to do now
oh ha ha all right I guess good so why
your mom fights really good
ah this is actually difficult this shot
hits every time Oh JJ what the [ __ ] did
you do what the [ __ ] did it out come
back here oh [ __ ] he's gonna do that one
alright alright alright miss me [ __ ]
oh ha ha ha ha ha
cuz I need a man I mean I need a woman
looking at me that is fractured oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm not gonna that's right Josh
ha
Woolridge respect mother just teleported
to the center I like that the mass could
change its phase even
I got the mascot that's all sir all
right let's do some damage with this
mask yes I want that baseball bat I
can't give that baseball man give me
that baseball bat my baseball bat
another five spread all over the screen
shut up
you broke at your broke at how my balls
all right it's gone here just because
just because where's this distract
Nick's distraction this did what
distract dyslexia hey hey hey girl I
know it's funny I'm the girl in the
dirty pictures ha ha what are you
talking about don't pretend you don't
know everybody knows knows what there's
posters of me all over town oh those now
everyone thinks I'm a [ __ ] great my
parents will be so proud I'll probably
get expelled look it could be worse how
how exactly could it be worse
I mean sure I've been a [ __ ] at times
been nasty but I don't deserve this
this yep found is over find one problem
is this big shuttle but not like this
everybody's laughing at me I can't bear
it everybody's always laughing at me
well maybe you're not as insecure as I
am okay I just wanted to be popular now
everybody hates me
yeah whatever makes for my nose those
I'll tell you what you wait here I'll
get rid of those posters for you or at
least cover them up would you I do it
myself but I can't deal with it I'm
really losing it here is your tail in
there okay so we gotta help this girl we
were the ones who took the pictures well
hopefully we can get laid that's it what
this game is all about laid simulator
BAM nay lad all right brothers I'm
actually gonna have to end this episode
here Thank You brothers for watching
like and favorite if you enjoyed what
the hell is going on what can I say
anyway uh-huh seven I'm walking like I'm
taking the guy just crapped my pants
what now oh honey yes